at a Las Vegas family is grieving in San
Diego tonight after they say their child
was seriously hurt in a crash thank you
for joining us at 11 I'm Brian Loftus
and I'm Denise
I'm Denise year old sits on life support
across state line they're asking for the
community's help to bring him home Sasha
Loftus joins us live tonight with more
on their message Denise and Brian this
family was just on the way back from a
vacation when their entire world changed
in a split second now they're just
trying to honor who their child was and
bring him back here to Las Vegas
everybody loved him it was impossible
not to love him Moses Sanchez and
Jocelyn Rodriguez share everything they
love about their son Ian he was the
littlest person in the room but he would
make himself appear as the biggest
person the six-year-old Las Vegas boy is
now on life support at a San Diego
hospital after the worst happened on the
way home from a family vacation the boy
that we knew that we loved he's not
there no more Moses says they were
driving on Interstate 215 in Murrieta
California near Temecula around 3 A.M
when they hit a driver that had crashed
into a wall the family says that person
was under the influence I couldn't stop
the entertainment I just hit him
straight on and his parents and his
brother were all taken to the hospital
but Ian is the only one who hasn't
recovered so then the leader sir I was
keeping him alive right now now as they
try to grasp the true gravity of this
tragedy Moses and Jocelyn are doing what
they can to honor Ian and bring him back
home here to the valley we're supposed
to be you know living to her
normal lives while also cherishing every
moment they had with this child they'll
always love and I want everyone to
remember how beautiful he was and how he
would bring the joy to other people
the family has set up a GoFundMe as they
raise money to bring Ian back here from
where he is at a children's hospital in
San Diego we have more info on our
website Denise